it has become a normal site in Greek
cities people queuing up in front of
cash machines in order to take out their
60 euros a day that's all Greek
customers are allowed to withdraw the
banks have now been closed for almost
three weeks a measure taken by the
government in order to prevent the
banking sector from collapsing this is
happening every day to every Greek we go
to the bank what did the ball almost if
something unexpected comes up there's no
more money to pay for anything extra
we'll make do for now but if something
unexpected comes up we don't know how
we'll handle it there's a sense of
insecurity we've had hefty
yem aspire but even though withdrawals
are restricted it's still costing the
banks an estimated 100 million euros
every day this cash is only available
because of the European Central Bank's
lifeline degrees known as ela or
emergency liquidity assistance many
expect the ECB's Governing Council to
extend the ELA limit of eighty nine
billion euros a move that would be seen
as a political decision to prevent the
banks from running out of cash before a
third bailout package is sealed